In 1982, Ridley Scott's tech-noir classic
Blade Runner was met with skeptical audiences
and empty theaters, thanks in part to a series
of slapdash changes made after low test screening
scores panicked the studio.
But now alternative versions of the movie
— more in line with the director's original
vision — are widely available to curious
viewers.
As a result, the film's popularity has risen
steadily over the years, along with a lot
of burning questions.
"Are you for real?"
No, seriously: is he?
Blade Runner depicts a near future in which
androids — known as replicants — are so
advanced that they're virtually indistinguishable
from the real thing.
And most of the debate surrounding the film
centers on whether its hero Rick Deckard,
played by Harrison Ford, is a human or a replicant.
Let's try to make some sense of it all.
The Origami Unicorn
So, is replicant-hunter Rick Deckard actually
an android?
This scene suggests the answer is a definite
yes.
After dreaming of a unicorn earlier in the
film, Deckard finds and fondles this origami
version — which must have been made by Eduardo
Gaff, the veteran LAPD blade runner and origami
maker who orders Deckard around.
But Deckard isn't exactly the type to open
up to his coworkers about his nighttime fantasies...
which means the only way Gaff could possibly
know Deckard dreams about unicorns is that
he's somehow read Deckard's memory file.
And if there's one thing we learn throughout
this movie, it's that...
Gaff is creepy
Who delivers Deckard's LAPD summons at a dirty
noodle bar?
Gaff.
Who creeps up behind Deckard as soon as he
retires the first of his assigned targets?
Gaff.
Who shows up immediately after Nexus 6 replicant
Roy Batty empties the contents of his soul
in the pouring rain?
Gaff!
And who knows all about Deckard's secret unicorn
dreams?
C'mon, don't make us say it again.
It's pretty clear that LAPD veteran Gaff is
monitoring Deckard.
But why would this so-called "one-man slaughterhouse"
need a leash?
Maybe because he's a replicant...only like
the film's femme fatale, Rachael, he doesn't
know it.
Who's the man?
Eduardo Gaff also drops one major hint that
the our blade runner hero might not be human
after all, after he's completed his mission
in a surprising, climactic moment.
"You've done a man's job, sir."
This is one of the most dissected, debated
lines in the film's history, and for good
reason: if you want to praise a guy for a
job well done, it's kind of a weird choice
of words, right?
That is, unless the man in question isn't
a man at all, but a robot, in which case it's
a heck of a compliment… and a good way to
tip off your audience as to Deckard's true
nature, in case they hadn't figured it out
yet.
The director's take
At this point, the evidence seems to be piling
up that Deckard is, indeed, a replicant — and
we haven't even mentioned how he survives
through multiple battles that would probably
leave an ordinary person in several pieces.
Or the split-second where his eyes seemed
to flash with the otherworldly glow that's
unique to the film's replicant characters.
But since nobody knows the truth better than
the man who made the movie, it probably makes
the most sense to just ask him.
Ridley Scott has already said that when it
comes to the Deckard question, "If you don't
get it, you're a moron."
But in an interview with Wired, he went into
detail for all us morons, saying:
"That's the whole point of Gaff, the guy who
makes origami and leaves little matchstick
figures around.
He doesn't like Deckard, and we don't really
know why.
If you take for granted for a moment that,
let's say, Deckard is a Nexus 7, he probably
has an unknown life span and therefore is
starting to get awfully human."
But wait, there's more
So, Rick Deckard is a replicant, has always
been a replicant, and will always be a replicant,
right?
Well... not so fast.
The dissenting opinion on that front is none
other than Harrison Ford, who says he and
Ridley Scott were always at odds over Deckard's
true nature.
"So I resisted the idea of being a replicant."
Ford felt that Blade Runner's audience should
have a human character to connect with — and
in the original theatrical cut of the film,
which was missing some of the key scenes that
brought Deckard's humanity into question,
Ford's interpretation makes more sense.
But when the director says Deckard is a replicant,
and the guy who plays Deckard says he's not,
it's hard to know who to believe… until
you remember that Deckard is ostensibly a
robot who only thinks he's a person, which
means that Ford's insistence otherwise could
just be a genius bit of method acting.
The more he shares his character's delusions,
the realer the film.
Right?
Right?!
The question is the answer
Pretty much everyone involved in Blade Runner
has an opinion on the is-he-or-isn't-he debate
about Rick Deckard — but author Philip K.
Dick, who wrote the book the movie was based
on, should get the last word.
And according to Dick, the ambiguity surrounding
Deckard's humanity — and more broadly, surrounding
whether there's any real difference between
humans and replicants — is kind of the whole
point.
It's a replicant who saves Deckard's life
and delivers the film's most poignant lines
before dying with grace and dignity.
When the replicants show more empathy than
the men who created them, which one of them
is more human?
What do the insights of a robot tell us about
the meaning of existence?
"They're just questions, Leon."
In other words, Blade Runner is designed to
make you think bigger, about the nature of
life itself — whether you're human, or something
more.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!